[Music]
i don't
like your tilted stage the
role you made me play of the fool no i
don't like you taylor swift is making it
clear her old self and old reputation
really are dead
i do it all the time the music video for
look what you made me do premiered at
sunday night's mtv video music awards
taylor seemingly addresses her public
feuds with katy perry kanye west and kim
kardashian here a bathtub scene taylor
dripped in diamonds could be a reference
to kim's paris robbery then check out
this imagery a snake literally pouring
taylor's tea here's a carving of the
words to brute translation even you
brutus from the play julius caesar when
julius gets stabbed to death by his
friend and here taylor dressed like katy
perry almost rubbing it in that kp
doesn't have a grammy by holding one in
the shot but the rest of the video
taylor takes aim at her own headline
making moments
references to her cat-loving self her
dominatrix-inspired bad blood squad and
yep that i heart ts shirt like we saw on
her ex tom hiddleston taylor also says
goodbye to her former music videos here
blank space and wildest dreams look what
you made me do look what you made me do
look what you just made me do and then
the rest of her video alter egos as they
try to hang on to new taylor's legs the
video ends with this conversation
between the ghosts of taylor swift's
past stop making that surprise face it's
so annoying you can't possibly be that
surprised all the time what's with that
[ __ ] don't call me that y'all oh stop
acting like you're all nice you are so
fake
oh there she goes playing the victim
again what are you doing getting
receipts you're gonna edit this later uh
i would very much like to be excluded
from this narrative
[Music]